all right we turn out to our most
accurate weather now forecast with Nate
Tannenbaum you staying cool at home Nate
well absolutely it's wonderful here at
the bowtie Nate home studio but Alex we
want to make sure everyone knows how
potentially dangerously hot it's going
to be this weekend we start with a live
picture from the mulaskey family's
company buildings downtown looking over
at the strat a couple of stray high
clouds but I think the more important
thing is it's a hundred and one degrees
already at noon two degrees warmer than
24 hours ago a little breeze out of the
East at 10:00 and let's run down the
excessive heat warning it starts
tomorrow morning at 10 runs all the way
through the weekend until 8 o'clock
Monday night and the National Weather
Service is now gone ahead and issued a
heat advisory for the higher elevations
they're usually left out of these things
but to make it up to 90 degrees in the
high country we'll talk more about that
but your weather headlines yeah that
excessive few warning again 10 Saturday
morning tomorrow till 8:00 Monday
evening the heat advisory in the
mountains we also have an update for you
on tropical storm Fay that's coming up
in a few minutes Alex